there were two
warriors i kill for a spicy tuna roll
right about now
get yourself a little something the
brothers grew apart
and a new age began in the middle
age dad is uncle 10 coming for christmas
this year
sweetie sometimes you just grow apart
diamond's all in my ring player go watch
gold chain player
walk in the building i own it i missed
you so much
that's my girl you can't solve
everything with money but you can't him
you haven't changed at all you're still
a big baby suck it ted
you suck out of my face excuse me
i hate to interrupt i mean it's a
riveting conversation but
i'm in the family business and now you
work for me
boomers
baby corp developed a new formula that
can turn a grown-up back into a baby for
48 hours
you want me to be a baby again
yep there's the awkward stage ew
baby corp will offer a full memory wipe
following this experience
so what's the crisis an evil genius is
teaching
kids to be very bad bad babies
welcome to the baby evolution
we're gonna need a disguise to go
undercover yeah what have you done to me
oh really we're going sailing oh no
thanks for always having my back you're
my brother we always stick together
because that's what families do
we need to hurry before the formula
wears off
what the [ __ ] aren't you a cutie in that
little karate outfit
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
i'm sure this isn't something money
can't solve
what the fudge
you